et dès le mois de juillet salahdine
louis xi est au téléphone pour joindre
chaque élève de 5e secondaire en
situation d'échec à la commission
scolaire marguerite bourgeoys
on évite ces jeunes de 16 à 18 ans au
saas le secondaire adapté à ta situation
comme moi je l'aimerais ont besoin
d'avoir preuve d'avoir moi qui explique
pas ce que je pense j'avais des faits
dans ta son chemin comme s'étend partout
cassandra avec quatre courts à refaire
pour obtenir son diplôme d'études
secondaires j'ai des prix peuvent et
m'avait
des mauvaises en 3,6 alors ça me le fait
puis à l'aller que je t'ai pu motiver à
mener qu'en fait croire ça veut dire que
ça dans ce qu'on considère être sixième
secondaire
la matière est concentré et les règles
souples tout en offrant beaucoup
beaucoup de soutiens mon prof
ils ont tourné dimanche sont dynamiques
avec une sont vraiment spécial ils sont
ensemble on this on s'entend donc il
disait ne jamais lâcher plus de
retraités phrase de manière différente
et deux fois plutôt qu'une
vingt fois plutôt qu'une parce que tu
arrêtes de manière différente dans la
tête de tout le monde autant que les
élèves qui sont en difficulté que ça
fait seize fois qu'ils font l'amour de
ma journée qui râlent en cours de match
lors jamais fait pincer 98
ce programme est offert à plus de 200
élèves ils ont jusqu'à un an pour le
réussir
mais le secret du saas et d'agir vite
mieux d'aller les chercher avant qu'ils
se disent non l'école c'est pas pour moi
j'aime mieux aller travailler
non ben c'est important d'aller leur
décote
oui tu peux aller travailler mais ça
serait mieux que tu ailles travail avec
un diplôme donc ce qu'on essaie de faire
c'est de ne pas les échappés trois cas
au mois de janvier dans les prochaine je
vais aller au sujet l'an dernier les
élèves du saas représenté 5% dès 2000 83
élèves ayant obtenu un diplôme ou une
certification à la commission scolaire
marguerite bourgeoys ce qui la place 3e
parmi les commissions scolaires
francophones avec un taux de réussite de
86% ici anne louise despatie
radio-canada mourir